you ever see those swamp people shows
where they have boats filled with
fucking alligators I don't think they're
eating those man I think most of those
they're just taking the skins off of
them and selling it for the leather yeah
that's that's what's really valuable
yeah I've no no adventure in me I watch
you posting videos of you hunting and
killing things and then eating it it's
like if you just go back to your your
Instagram three days in a row it's like
I could watch like a an animal alive to
being on your plate and it's fucking
Ivan more power to you dude the whole
thing I'm I watch it in awe because I
could never I could never kill something
even an even like I don't even Utley
could kill something lying to me you
could kill something and you definitely
could if you wanted to feed your son
there's no doubt in my mind if you had a
gun and there was a deer and you were
hungry starving yes you don't even have
to be starving you just have to have not
the best prospect manifesting right now
it's like 11:00 a.m. I'll fuckin what is
this Jamie 46 grams of protein an
alligator is that a pound 3.3 ounces
holy shit three ounces of alligator 46
grams of protein are you gainers out
there of course it's a goddamn murderous
dinosaur it's got no fat on it it's just
muscle and run style skin they're
monsters man terrifying they're you that
story about like though like that's the
other thing about becoming a father that
people don't tell you everything makes
you terrified oh yeah so you know this
so I'm supposed to put my kid at Disney
in July and I'm like there was a story
with the alligator who grabbed a little
kid and dragged him into the I'm the
property of Disney yep the father just
watch this kid get eaten
dude Florida there's too many alligators
they can't keep track of them so if you
have a body of water and you're not
standing there 24/7 when the fucking
spotlight and rifle those Punk's can
sneak into that water that's it that's
real shit man yeah they'll sneak into
that water they'll cross that grass you
don't know they're there they climb in
that water you don't know they're there
and they'll be underwater for an hour
two hours and they'll pop that little
head up they see that little kid now
goddamn I'm hungry that kids too close
to water and let's just grab them they
don't have any qualms about that they
don't know what the fuck you are they
don't care what you are yeah they have a
brain the size of a goddamn walnut and
they've been alive in that form for who
knows how many fucking millions of years
and they just kill you take they can go
without food for a year man really 95
alligators removed
from Disney property in Orlando Fox
toddler killed 95 that was just like in
that last year this was years ago and
this isn't written dude there to live up
to 400 alligators through April like
it's a project like they're building a
fucking bridge